this is jake from geek culture and today
we're taking a look at microsoft's
lineup for next generation consoles so
first up we have the less powerful
but
in my opinion more sleek looking xbox
series s
followed by its bigger more intimidating
uh cousin
the most powerful console ever according
to microsoft
the xbox series x so let's talk about
the series s and the series x so what
are the main differences so obviously as
you can see the size difference is
pretty huge
with the series s coming in at a much
smaller footprint compared to the series
x so in terms of performance wise there
are big differences as well so for the
series s is digital only and the series
x comes with a disk drive where you can
play your ultra uh
ultra blu-ray hd whatever you know you
know how it goes and then uh in terms of
performance yeah we're looking at uh
both
are running 120 frames per second with
xbox series x capable of going up to 4k
well the xbox series s is up to 1440p
and then as for the teraflops i think
that's the most important thing for a
lot of people out there if you don't
know the technicalities behind the
systems and the architecture so for the
xbox series x is running at 12.15
teraforms compared to the four teraflops
there on the xbox series s those are the
main differences that you can look
forward to when you're checking out the
two different consoles so let's start
with the series s and take a look what's
inside the box when you get one so here
we go as we open it up
we have the very very adorable very very
tiny
console right here the xbox use s we'll
open it up later
so included with the packaging is a
getting started guide
and of course
we have all the accessories here
we got the standard hdmi cable
as well as of course the power cable if
not you're not going to run your console
and then we got another guide here is
this the
what is this
this is just the product and regulation
guide which i'm sure most of you would
throw away the moment you open your box
and then of course
a new console
comes with its own controller
trying very hard not to tear this
so
we're taking a look at the new
controller here as you can see all white
pure nice lines
and of uh if you didn't know
the xbox likes to run
on battery so we have two double a
batteries here as well
there you go
now let's take a look at what's hiding
underneath the packaging for the xbox
series s
as it says here power your dreams
or you know power up to 1440p at 120
frames per second
it's all packed very nicely here
and there you have it the xbox series s
it looks exactly like what we have seen
on the internet it looks like a giant
speaker
there are lots of ventilation holes so
hopefully we're not getting more red
rings of death here let's take a look at
the front so let's take a look at what's
on the front of the xbox series s we
have obviously the power button or slick
in line with the console and then we
have the i guess this is what you
what button used to connect your
bluetooth accessories to including your
xbox controller and we have a usb port
here as well
then let's take a look at the back
so here we have the ethernet port
two
usb ports as well as the hdmi out and of
course we got the new storage expansion
card slot here that we'll get into later
and then of course the power cable here
so as you can see this is a very slick
no frills packaging
when it comes to the xbox series s
it should fit right nicely into any home
entertainment setup it's really really
small and then it's supposed to perform
at a very very
high standard
almost the same as the xbox
xbox one x but not as powerful but for
those looking for an alternative to the
xbox series x this is something that you
can consider adding to your home setup
so as mentioned the xbox series s comes
with 512 gigs of storage but let's be
honest here that's not enough for all
modern gamers out there so if you're
looking for additional storage options
you have the ability to plug in an hdd
or better yet let's have this solution
right for you this seagate storage
expansion card that comes with an
additional one terabyte of storage for
either the xbox series s or the xbox
series x
but what's great about this
new expansion card it's running on the
same
i guess it's running the same design and
architecture as the internal ssd inside
your console so there is no hit for your
performance uh
no matter where you store your games
whether it be on this storage cart or on
your internal ssd so it goes right
behind here the console in this storage
expansion slot
there you go easy peasy and now your
xbox series s has an additional one
terabyte of storage running at the same
performance and same speeds as you would
expect as uh for the games that are
running off your consoles all right now
we're moving let's move on to the start
of the show the xbox series x
so this is one
hefty package that's what she said
now let's take a look at this compared
to the s look at how big this
this rectangular tower of power is so
aside from the console here we have the
xbox series s we have a starter guide
same as the xbox series s
and then just look at this packaging
though it just screams premium and
high-tech
product right at you and of course you
know with that comes a hefty price but
it's going to be worth it i'm sure so we
have the power cable
as well as the hdmi cable
so
here you go same thing product guide
then we move on to
the controller so for the series s we
got a white
xbox controller
and then for
the series s
s fitting we got a matte black contour
it looks really really good feels great
to the touch
it's got this texture if you can see
this texture is very nice it should help
with the grip
and then of course we have the 2a
battery so we'll not take a look at that
right now
so
moving on let's unpack this baby
this
black beast as you would the most
powerful xbox console ever
let's look at this
all
right come on come on
there you go so straight off the bat you
can see this is the stand
for your xbox series x so you know
exactly where to go and of course these
are the
cushioning that you will have if you
want to place it flat down instead of
standing up so we have it standing up
first
so there you have it the xbox series x
in all its naked glory uh so this is the
front of the most powerful xbox console
we got a look at the power button which
is the xbox symbol
the bluetooth button over here a usb
slot at the front and of course don't
forget this is different from the xbox
series s we've got a blu-ray drive over
here
and then we turn it around
let's take a look at this
so similar slots to the xbox series s
you got the ethernet port here two ultra
fast usb slots uh the power this is
where the power cable goes in the hdmi
out and of course the storage expansion
slot
that we have that will house the
propriety xbox storage expansion card
here there's also an interesting
inclusion of a kensington lock slot here
so you know just in case you don't want
your kids to be slinging away your most
powerful xbox consoles this is where you
need to put that kensington lock so what
we don't have here let's come back to
the last generation or no current
generation xbox one x or xbox one is the
lack of any i guess entertainment or tv
ports here such as pass-throughs and
whatnot so as you can see xbox is taking
it seriously for this generation uh they
want it to be your gaming machine the
one gaming machine that you need to rule
them all and of course if you didn't
know
there are a lot of vans on the xbox
series x
which is great for those of us who know
hate your consoles heating up or you
know the fans running at a very high
speed the additional this vents and the
powerful fan uh i'm not sure if you can
see it over here
those will hopefully help dissipate all
the heat from your consoles and keep
everything running fresh smooth and
quickly so there you have it there's
also some green
highlights here that you can't really
catch on camera and should be a perfect
addition to your new home entertainment
setup
so as mentioned
the xbox series x comes with
a sizable one terabyte of storage
already but if that's not enough yeah it
is never enough
we have the
seagate expansion card here again so
similar to the xbox series s
all you need to do
plug in this baby right here and there
you go you have an additional one
terabyte of storage running at the exact
same speed as your internet ssd
so there you have it uh geek culture's
unboxing of both the xbox series x and
the xbox series s a quick and dirty look
at the next generation of gaming thanks
to microsoft and xbox so we have unboxed
them show you what they're all about so
you don't have to so in case you've been
wondering what's at this side of the
table here this is the exclusive xbox
royale gaming chair so if you're a gamer
looking to complement your new xbox
series x or s you look no further than
this xbox royale edition gaming chair
decked out in perfect green and black
very very suitable for your xbox series
x king deserves his gaming throne and
there's nothing better for xbox gamer
than this xbox royale gaming chair
it comes with some special features of
its own beside its black and green
aesthetic you have this very nice
stitching at the back of an achievement
unlocked get a thousand gamer score just
for being an xbox series s or x gamer
and then on the front we have the xbox
teaching here over right here the the
gaming uh logo here
oh yeah i mentioned you can't buy this
anywhere you have to be a lucky winner
and to
participate in this giveaway of sorts
all you need to do is just pre-order
either the xbox series s or the xbox
series x at four participating retailers
they are chishan
harvey norman challenger
and game mats specific only to dose here
in singapore
so if you're outside of singapore i'm
sorry you won't get to bring home this
amazingly designed chair and so if you
just happen to be a lucky winner of this
xbox royale gaming chair not only are
you going to get your gamertag
embroidered on the royale cushion
it will also come in a glow in the dark
stitching which is the same for this
xbox logo right in the center perfect
for those late night gaming and you know
scaring people as they walk past your
office now that we have both the xbox
series s and the xbox series x out here
let's just power them up and see how it
goes let's get ready for the next
generation of console gaming
oh guys
wow
no way oh my god